frustrated
[Music]
well listen CAE is one of the leading
providers of Aviation training in the
world this is their first operations on
the west coast you know listen we have
preach we have Nellis Air Force Base
we're right next door to Harry Reid
International Airport this is just a
perfect complement to our aviation
industry here in southern Nevada
bringing people in and also building on
our veterans who are here over half of
the employee Workforce here at CAE are
veterans many of them coming out of
Nellis and preach so just a great
opportunity to expand our economy expand
our economic diversification here in
southern Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
push it push it forward
A real plane
there you go it's good it's natural it's
like a video okay
there's a problem
oh that's the power
it's not a car
okay so where was the
way
back CA brings really outstanding paying
jobs to Southern Nevada and potentially
over 100 of them
to our ability to attract people into
Southern Nevada take advantage of the
assets that we have here and employ
people with great jobs really just
builds the entire community
here's the clear skies and smooth
Landings wherever the air Ventures take
them cheers to see Las Vegas